let's just cut to the chase friends
while the rest of the world is getting
ready to see black panther wakanda
forever in a few months i've got my eyes
set to the movie right after it ant-man
quantum mania why should i care about
the third movie in the ant-man trilogy
oh because that's where ant-man is gonna
die and i'm about to prove it to you
hello internet welcome to film theory
where the smallest details transform
into huge pieces of evidence case in
point today's episode you see even
before this year's comic con it'd been
pretty well established that kang the
conqueror was gonna be the mcu's next
thanos level overarching threat there's
been no shortage of articles and
interviews confirming that when it comes
to marvel this is the guy that you're
gonna need to watch out for and now that
the next avengers movie is straight up
called the kang dynasty forget about it
case closed so far we've only gotten our
first tease of kang in the mcu as this
big over excited exposition dump during
the final episode of loki but in the
comics he's actually a multiversal
warmonger a guy who lives with the
unlimited lives cheat code on not only
does kang have infinite violent variants
floating around the infinite timelines
kang's future technology is so advanced
that he's able to transfer his
consciousness to a new body at the
moment of his death the dudes like rick
sanchez minus the existential apathy and
don't get me wrong a citadel of rick's
vs avengers showdown is certainly
interesting in theory but it ultimately
might ring hollow if there's no stakes
behind it thanos wasn't just an era
defining villain cause he was powerful
if we learned anything from that galaxy
brain grimace a box office mega villain
needs to earn their place by altering
the status quo drastically they need to
prove that they're an existential threat
to our favorite plot armored heroes they
need to make our blood boil with the
rage of revenge and the fear of loss in
short someone's gotta get dusted kang
has to prove himself as the next major
threat by killing off a beloved hero and
that hero is gonna be ant-man yep i
predict that ant-man in the final movie
of his trilogy is gonna get exterminated
like a bug which you know is it's it's
fitting first let's start things off by
examining the general story structure of
the mcu no you can't get to the end
until you've been changed by the journey
thanks for that kang see this guy knows
what he's talking about no i mean
absolutely no disrespect to stan lee
stands by saying this but the mcu runs
on some pretty tried and true story
formulas at this point i think it's
pretty fair to say that we're all at
least vaguely familiar with the
narrative beats of the iconic heroes
journey called adventure find a mentor
death and rebirth that results in some
sort of a transformation atonement and
then returning back to the beginning
changed as a result classic stuff been
done to death but exactly like that
overarching end bosses hit key beats in
their stories as well you can certainly
see the pattern in self-contained
stories but it's especially apparent
when you start looking at memorable big
baddies of epic adventure franchises
first the big villain appears in a film
technique that steven spielberg likes to
call the fraction introduction this is
where the audience is teased about the
mystery surrounding this new character
for thanos this fraction tease came as
his cameo at the end of the first
avengers film pegging him as the true
mastermind behind loki's chittari
invasion harry potter had evil lord
voldemort appearing as just a face on
the back of professor quarle's head at
the end of the first movie showing the
big boss as the motivating force for a
lesser antagonist is a common trope
that's used to express this particular
plot point think of fire lord ozai's
silhouette ordering zuko to hunt down
the avatar or grand moff tarkin named
dropping the emperor in a new hope i've
just received word that the emperor has
dissolved the council permanently
implying that even darth vader answers
to someone higher up on the food chain
as the plot moves into act 2 we're given
a taste of the villain's true power it's
common for writers to give us hints of
this through the use of specific story
beats known as pinch points these pinch
points are moments that amp up the
narrative tension by putting our heroes
in a jam through increasing doses of the
villain's intensifying presence
traditionally there are two major pinch
points that happen on opposite ends of
the story's second act the first is
usually early in act 2 and it's just a
simple reminder of the villain's
strength the second foreshadows the
biggest complication that the villain
will throw at our heroes oftentimes an
important character gets killed in the
process in harry potter the first key
pinch showcasing the threat of voldemort
is the death of cedric diggory in goblet
of fire the second pinch point comes
when dumbledore himself is killed off in
movie six right before the final push
towards the end battle for the infinity
saga thanos's first pinch point comes
when he enlists ronan the accuser to get
the power stone in guardian's galaxy
through ronin we are given the glimpse
of the destruction that'll spread
throughout the universe as thanos
completes his rock collection the second
pinch point is at the start of infinity
war when thanos decimates the asgardians
boxes the previously unbeatable hulk
into retirement and drives home that
even the slippery loki can't escape his
inevitability loki's death is the
linchpin of the pinch point without it
the stakes wouldn't be high enough for
the audience to care in one scene thanos
decimates what have otherwise been
indestructible heroes giving us a sense
of the real threat that he poses which
brings us then to their moment of
victory after years of scheming in the
shadows the villain finally achieves
their goal when it comes to sprawling
franchise level narratives this moment
often happens in the second to last
installment leaving us on a cliffhanger
so that both fans and heroes have to sit
through their darkest hour for years
waiting for resolution just think about
the king of this trope star wars the
empire strikes back where han ends the
movie as a big old ice cube and luke
loses a hand for the infinity saga this
moment is when thanos bests earth's
mightiest heroes and dusts half the
universe this structure achieves two
purposes first it underlines the
strength of the threat but more
importantly it turns our heroes into
underdogs it's not certain whether or
not they'll be able to prevail the next
installment then means that the heroes
have to win back every inch of the world
that they wish to fix ultimately making
the climactic battle feel that much more
earned so those are your lessons from
the screenplay and according to this
time-tested story formula we can look at
kang's confirmed appearances in the mcu
to deduce how he might be similarly
utilized across multiple movies in order
to truly rise to the role of the next
big bad right now we've seen kang's
first teaser moment in the season 1 loki
finale and boy was that a journey on its
own throughout the season we see
timelines getting deleted infinity
stones turning into meaningless rocks
and a hangry cloud monster that devours
all matter this leads us to the citadel
at the end of time a big scary castle
with big dramatic doors and a massive
tension building elevator with the
entire series building to this moment
loki has reached the one pulling the
strings behind the whole operation the
elevator doors open and kang it's his
thanos first reveal moment and this
isn't even a particularly violent kang
either sure he's created a big brother
organization run by puppets that prunes
entire timelines but he tells us that
all of this is to keep his other more
violent selves at bay if you think i'm
evil this way till you meet my variants
with just one timeline there's just one
kang and he warns that his death is
going to unleash a pandora's box of
crueler variants so of course he dies
only to have everything start to unravel
looking more broadly right now the
multiverse is in flux with movies like
no way home and multiverse of madness
while kang isn't connected to either of
those events yet those movies are
already priming us for kang's impending
multiversal war we're starting to learn
the rules and the dangers that accompany
wild multiversal collisions just like
the infinity saga introduced us one by
one to the powers and dangers of the
individual stones via movies that were
completely disconnected from thanos the
reality stone in thor 2 the time stone
and doctor strange the tesseract and
avengers to power stoning guardians that
way when everything comes together with
kang all the rule setting in world
building has already been done in
previous movies all of this means that
if we consult the handy dandy story
cheat sheet the next time we'll be
interacting with kang will be the pinch
points and hey wouldn't you know it but
we have two projects next year that have
that pair of pinch points one of these
has to be loki season 2 due out in
mid-2023 this one's obvious because at
the end of season one of loki we see
giant kang statues in the new layout of
the rebooted tva safe to say that kang
is gonna play a huge role in loki's
return which means that there's gonna be
plenty of time to get those pinches in
but the other pinch point is gonna come
even sooner than that with quantum
mania's release in february of 2023 and
that one is gonna be the death pinch
this is wild and here's where the theory
gets interesting loyal theorists i
submit to you exhibit a a minor leaked
image from quantum mania's
pre-production these shirts were
allegedly made for quantum mania stunt
team depicting a broken ant-man helmet
and the reflection of kang the conqueror
ominously charging an energy blast now
third installments of mcu films
historically end with the destruction of
a hero's iconic equipment iron man 3 had
tony hit the fireworks button on his
whole iron closet captain america civil
war had steve rogers renounce his shield
and thor ragnarok shattered mjolnir like
it was made out of lego what this means
is that scott lang might just be left to
face the nearly immortal time demigod
kang with only his wits and huh well
those aren't great odds and i'm not the
only one to notice the power imbalance
here back in october of 2021 jonathan
majors actor for kang the conqueror was
interviewed on the late night show jimmy
kimmel when he's questioned on how
ant-man would possibly be able to
contend with someone of kang's power we
get this no offense to ant-man but kang
if kang is a thanos yeah it's like
squash ant-man's dead
we'll see look at that face seems to me
that kimmel guessed right and majors
gives him a little too much reveal with
that facial response that my friends is
a man who has realized that kevin
feige's snipers are on the way so from a
narrative angle it's the perfect time
for ant-man to die we have t-shirts from
the production showing that ant-man is
gonna get wrecked and we have kang's
actor giving us some guilty vibes and
interviews but there's still one more
piece of evidence that you need to see
avengers number 500 the first part of
the avengers disassembled comic arc that
brought about an end to the avengers
team spoiler alert in this issue ant-man
dies now admittedly it isn't at the
hands of kang the conqueror but the
ripple effects of his death end up
playing an important role in both kang's
development and the evolution of the
avengers you see scott lang's death is
very comic booky he's killed when the
zombie corpse of his best friend
unexpectedly explodes this all turns out
to be the result of a grieving scarlet
witch inadvertently tampering with the
fabric of reality but it's not the how
of this comic that's important it's the
why you see scott's death is incredibly
important because it's the catalyst that
sets in motion the formation of the
young avengers one of the key members is
scott's daughter cassie lang who is so
moved by scott's death that she takes up
the ant-man legacy under the code name
stature and forms the team in order to
avenge him and hey wouldn't you know it
but the quantum mania poster and footage
from comic con showed us that cassie is
gonna suit up just like her dad in the
new movie it doesn't hurt that the
cassie actress from endgame also got
recast with a bigger name too without
even telling said actress that she was
being recast bad luck there marvel bad
luck now it's pretty clear that the
young avengers are coming to the big
screen nearly every phase 4 property has
introduced or will introduce a potential
young avenger many of whom are the
founding members of the team in the
comics one division gave us billy and
tommy aka wiccan and speed hawkeye gave
us kate bishop loki opened the door for
kid loki multiverse and madness gave us
america chavez and falcon in the winter
soldier gave us patriot heck i wouldn't
be surprised if hulkling pops up in
she-hulk her secret invasion then you
also have to consider the potential
applications of miss marvel and
ironheart who are coming and teens and
prime candidates for the mcu's young
avengers lineup clearly the building
blocks for this team are being assembled
now we just need the event that gets
them all together ant-man's death just
like in the comics but you want to know
the real clincher kang is actually the
first villain that the young avengers
take on in the comics it's only fitting
that he play a role in their live-action
debut and to go even more subatomic on
this theory if kang the conqueror is
running with ant-man goes as badly for
scott as i think it's gonna that one
kill doesn't just mold the villain that
all these new heroes are gonna have to
band together against in phase five it's
also gonna shape the entirety of phase
six what if unlike thanos kang gets a
redemption arc and becomes a young
avenger you see kang has a zillion
variants but one of them is a young
avenger in fact he's their first leader
a teen variant of kang going by the
alias iron lad forms the team in hopes
that he can divert himself from growing
up to become a megalomaniac that brings
about the destruction of the multiverse
iron lad even has a close sometimes
romantic relationship with cassie lang
in the comics this poses an interesting
conflict if kang turns out to be the one
to squash ant-man at their core the
ant-man movies are thematically about
second chances scott is an ex-felon
who's given a second lease on life hank
pym gets a second chance at saving his
wife janet the ant family helps save and
redeem ghosts in the second film if kang
kills cassie's father she's put in a
scenario where she may have to give her
father's killer a pre-emptive second
chance as well so if cassie chooses to
forgive young kang that may be the push
iron lad needs to avoid his dark future
saving the multiverse from adult kang in
the process or maybe the second chance
kang gets in quantomania is at killing
scott when they meet during the trailer
shown at comic con scott introduces
himself to kang as an avenger kang's
response you're an avenger have i killed
you before so when ant-man starts
advertising itself like yet another
quirky superhero comedy star in paul
rudd you'll know the truth at some point
that thing is going to take a serious
turn and pull the rug out from under you
stomping the main man himself out of
existence either that or you know
ant-man shrinks himself and hops up
kang's butt hey that's just a theory a
film theory and cuts
[Music]